in 2018 North America went further at
Worlds than ever before and going in to
2019 the one question on everyone's mind
is how can they go even further one way
is for the region to lean on their wiki
Talent
you might not be used to North American
amateurs taking over the world
but if 2018 taught us anything is that
the next generation of talent is the
future of na before the NA LCS franchise
right implemented scouting grounds to
give up-and-coming players a chance to
get noticed by LCS teams when we
describe it to people outside of the
scene we certainly refer to it as our
combine right it's the League of Legends
Academy combine or the LCS combine this
is a developmental platform where people
can come and get recognition and
hopefully get picked up by a team you
know we're gonna try to open up scouting
grounds a lot more for a lot of
different paths and really provide an
amateur ecosystem that's centered around
scouting runs and once franchising
kicked in this past year right replaced
a challenger series with the Academy
League which forced every LCS team to
have a second roster made up of mostly
rookies so now that this franchising
teams are able to have you know a
secondary roster or make some changes
without fear of losing the only you know
like revenue source that they have
that's why you see c9 and doing those
kind of things you saw Equifax retaining
players in and out given time they'll
become more and more of a popular thing
and you'll start to see more talent come
out these structures were designed so
the teams would look locally when
signing new players as opposed to just
bringing in as many imports as the rules
would possibly allow them and when
cloud9 made top four at World partially
thanks to incredible play from their
rookies it became clear that even na a
region that often barely makes it into
the Worlds bracket stage can turn
amateurs into international contenders
and I do love the combination of rookies
and veterans that this squad has
developed because recently we've been
seeing a lot more reliance and sense
Garen / blabber and while it mentally
blabbered didn't have the best planes
performance and we did see a lot of
growth throughout the tournament for him
but now they're relying on svenska
combining him with the rookies of
licorice and asel and you seem to have
this mesh of a squad that seems to
really know what they're doing when they
come into these big games in the past
the issue with North American talent
wasn't so much that it wasn't there is
that it was underdeveloped and in many
cases ignored after 2014 like a lot of
the Koreans started leaving Korea so
there became like this rush to get as
many Koreans as you can like the best
players that you could the ones that
really wanted to come over so I think
that kind of like hindered anaise own
talent growth just because they weren't
really looking at themselves they're
kind of just looking all around it yeah
I mean it's just been like this thing
that a realization that there are really
good players in na that haven't been
discovered yet ha 9 was really the first
to show that na rookies can have a
world-class potential and there's no
better example of that than their
jungler blabber not only was he promoted
from their Academy team but he was also
discovered through scouting and with the
ninth pick of the North American
scouting grounds draft cloud9 selects
blabber fish to
[Applause]
you can trace our whole amateur scene
through cloud 9
so blabber was at scouting grounds was
signed at scouting grounds I came
through the you know came right into the
Academy team and then got shot right
into the LCS and wound up on a world
stage I mean that's like that's amazing
progression in virtually every way
blabber is the perfect poster boy for na
rookies I don't know if you really need
more proof
like even before I got picked up by
cloud 9 I did like anime and I was like
yeah like and they're like what still
the key players do you think are good
I'm like well I played hazel I think
he's good and blabber fish shoe and like
soloqueue I run into him I think he's
gonna be like really good and then like
glow and hold like a year and a half
later like I'm playing with him on LCS
stage that said a single explosive
season doesn't change the fact that of
the four major regions na has the
smallest player base and the most
approves if na is seriously gonna
compete with the rest of the world it
needs to value is rookies just as much
as the rest of the world does so let's
look at the full major regions right
North America Europe Korea and China
let's talk about the two regions that
produces rookies that take over the
world Europe and Korea let's talk about
the two regions that produces the most
famous people on the planet North
America and China you've got two regions
that value and develop and foster
different aspects of professional life
and I think it's exciting to see that
both Europe and Korea continually digs
up these diamonds in the rough
that take over their local scene and
then shows up on an international tour
Europe has a proven track record of
turning domestic talent from caps to
perks to brock's it into international
competitors and this year during na is
international coming-out party cloud9
Wallis to fnatic a European team that
went on to the finals if na is gonna
compete with that then the region needs
to put a little bit more confidence in
its talent pool I think Europe has just
always have a really big player base and
a lot look really really good mechanical
players and like it just feels like the
player pool is so deep and well Europe
as wall has always been known for their
good mid laners so in our cases while it
felt that the health of leaving that
doesn't good option to choose from and I
think pulling in someone like nemesis
it's really exciting it's always cool to
see groupies come into the league and
see how they do the question going
forward is whether other teams can
coffee what cloud9 did and run with it
it's possible that the strategy was a
fluke call 9 just happened to sign some
incredible players for their academy
team and they just happen to be ready
for the world stage as soon as they got
there
I think they cloud9 had the benefit of
having like by far the strongest academy
roster out of like any team so they had
like Keith McCray and golden blue who
are like LCS ready players hazel who was
like basically LCS ready when he was
playing Academy blogger fish who like is
an interesting player but like he did
well in the Osseo stage and then even
like Shiro is like looked at as one of
the best Academy Tops
so like I think we had the benefit of
having a really strong roster and it's
hard for another team to just like
replicate but but there's no denying
that their historic season can change
things and we're already starting to get
a glimpse of what that future might look
like I'm not gonna go out and say that
North America's rookie talent is greater
than China or Europe's rookie talent
because I think those teams with larger
player bases in a larger history of
working them up through the pro scene
have proven to be better but I will say
for North America teams are paying
attention to it again and that could be
the start of something what we're also
seeing is a change in the mentality from
the players themselves for years
whenever an na team went up against a
big international competitor it was kind
of assumed that they would just lose
double lifters are going Samsung blue
are you going with clubs on it why
Samsung was just the clear favorite see
I'm going with them absolutely 3 2 1
[Music]
before will win the best-of-five
prediction time for this finals at MSI
who's walking away with the title krepo
starting with you I mean you know almost
the obvious skp it's more of a question
where there's three zero three one I'm
just gonna go with the 3-0 at least make
it a little pulse so there's a chance
with me being wrong didn't did throw co2
the air he picks his hands up as SKT
I've got four members down they turn
their attention to the Nexus and SK
Telecom continued to rule the world and
they are your midseason Invitational
champions
but some of North America's newest
rookies aren't feeling the weight of
their predecessors bag for these
up-and-coming players the international
stage isn't something to fear it's a
place to prove themselves will come in
short the flash is available to crown
gets knocked up in the air by the flag
is going down you I mean hit points the
winds of war on flashed away from slappa
this substitute gets first flies aboard
now they go over the wall here comes the
dive sneaky it's landing right back out
and they put on a milesg he's got a
flash way he's slowed the flash forward
a stop to buy time but he's certainly
going to fall with a huge available
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]